[Music]
on this Tuesday night urgent calls for
calm and Canada's rail crisis to end the
prime minister in the line of fire we
are extending our hands in good faith
for dialogue dialogue is not going to
pay the bills for people who are facing
layoffs and Andrew Shearer speech that
got him shut out of a leaders meeting
China's unprecedented rules to contain
kovat 19 they don't want the virus to
return to other places and concerns
spreading in a Canadian city terrified
plus a discovery of astronomical
proportions the science redefining how
planets were formed
[Music]
global national with Donna freezing
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with breaking
news the rail blockade crisis is now
having a direct impact on jobs CN is
temporarily laying off about 450
employees due to the protests that have
crippled Canada's transportation network
and the economy the Prime Minister took
heed in the House of Commons today over
his handling of the situation Justin
Trudeau says he's committed to dialogue
with indigenous protestors but says the
solution will not be simple the
opposition says it's time the government
stepped in and did something dialogue is
not going to pay the bills for people
who are facing layoffs because of people
breaking the law
we will exhaust every action possible to
resolve this situation peacefully and
rapidly the Assembly of First Nations is
calling for calm and tonight the House
of Commons is holding an emergency
debate over the crisis sparked by
support of the hereditary Chiefs in BC
opposed to a natural gas pipeline
running through what so itand territory
Via Rail is preparing to resume some
passenger service in southwestern
Ontario but as abigail Beeman reports in
our top story tonight the dispute is
still far from over the rail blockade
near Belleville Ontario still standing
after nearly two weeks I know that
people's patience is running short we
need to find a solution and we need to
find it but the Prime Minister does not
yet have one to offer and the leader of
the official opposition slammed him for
that standing between our country and
prosperity is a small group of radical
activists many of whom have little to no
connection to First Nations communities
I think what he said was a so divisive
that it rises to love racism the Prime
Minister continues to call for peace and
constructive dialogue Ottawa has been
offering a face-to-face meeting with
some of the wet sweat and hereditary
chiefs in BC this has to be their
invitation
Minister Miller said that there is not a
lot of trust and there is a an ongoing
difficulty they told me they want to
create their own approach to formalise
discussions with the federal provincial
governments the crown and they need to
be given that time the National chief of
the Assembly of First Nation says there
are options for a way forward that may
ultimately bring down the blockades
but the wet sweat and people need to be
given a respect and space to choose
their own path
there could be options like peacekeepers
like their own tribal police but that
can come from themselves one grand chief
believes if the protests continue they
will become self-defeating Serge Otzi
simon says indigenous people too will
suffer from potential propane or food
shortages do we look at the rail
blockades as having served its purpose
for now I'm simply pleading with these
with the protesters that have you made
your point yet as the government and
Industry understood I think they did but
to show how divisive this issue is for
suggesting the blockade should end Simon
has been pad locked out of his own band
council office with calls for him to
resign Abigail the debate over the
pipeline has sure spilled over into the
political realm in Ottawa well Robyn
Tuesday night MPs are holding an
emergency debate called for by the NDP
and the bloc québécois
as an example of how divisive the
politics are both among indigenous
people and here elected parliamentary
politicians this afternoon Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau held a meeting
with opposition leaders but he didn't
invite the official opposition leader
conservative Andrew Shearer Trudeau's
office said the Conservatives are only
offering quote force and aggression as a
solution Shearer says the meeting was a
distraction from Trudeau's inaction
Robyn Abigail Beeman in Ottawa you heard
an Abigail story one grand chief with a
strong opinion on the ongoing blockades
he wants protesters to step aside here's
more of his message to them the
blockades doesn't mean that you
surrender like I said a wall of it
doesn't mean we're gonna just lay down
and let them kick us a kick us around no
but he would show compassion along with
the strength
other people are suffering across the
country because of this blockade and not
just non-indigenous the indigenous
people as well shortages in propane and
probably food supplies are gonna are
gonna start getting critical if this
continues so it will be a self-defeating
purpose to continue on with the blockade
so I'm hoping that reason and peace are
going to prevail and that the message is
going to continue on there was also a
message today for the people calling for
police intervention one Grand chief
spoke about past mistakes and the need
to learn from history to those people
who are quick to pull the pin and to to
come down hard or demand that hard
things it's 30 years ago since since the
what they called the oka crisis it's not
that long ago with the camp paper washed
and people you wrote that and use that
as a as a reminder to themselves we
should use restraint nobody wants to see
that again you've heard mentioned there
of oka and if ur wash both are examples
of the need for peaceful negotiation
here's a reminder of what happened
oka unfolded in 1990 the small village
in Quebec became a flashpoint when the
mayor announced plans for a golfcourse
expansion and condo development project
on disputed land that included a mohawk
burial ground protestor set up a
blockade to stop construction crews and
for months they refused to budge in july
1990 the mayor called in provincial
police to tear down the blockade that
sparked chaos gunfire was reported from
both sides and a police corporal was
shot and killed
solidarity protests continued until
Quebec called in the Army in August
protests ended in September and the
development project was eventually
canceled but the land has still not been
transferred
five years after oka in 1995 another
conflict over land unfolded this time at
a fur wash Provincial Park in Ontario
at issue was the stony point reserved
which the federal government took in the
1940s for use as a military camp the
kettle and stony point First Nation
repeatedly asked for the land back but
with little movement they grew
frustrated in September 1995 protesters
occupied a per wash provincial park the
Ontario Provincial Police were called in
and violence unfolded on September 6 of
that year a [ __ ] [ __ ] protester Dudley
gorge was killed
an inquiry later found significant
problems with police and government
response in 2015 the First Nation
accepted a 95 million dollar settlement
from the federal government which
included the land the Premier of
Newfoundland and Labrador is adamant his
decision to resign has absolutely
nothing to do with scandals inside his
Liberal Party sources suggest white
balls performance has fractured the
caucus and cabinet but ball says that's
not the issue and he just wants to spend
more time with his family here's Ross
Lord it's been less than a year since
Dwight balls liberals were reelected
with a minority government no one
expected the next chapter to end so soon
with balls sudden resignation it was all
about you know what was best for my
family and the fact that I just wasn't
ready to run for another election
nothing that just wasn't ready I just
didn't want to political observers
wonder if ball is moving away from his
political family they say members of the
provincial Liberal caucus and others
with connections to the party have been
unhappy with his leadership for the most
part he was just a smiling suit you know
he was more about the brand he was about
gaining credit and avoiding blame and
part of that avoiding blame I think
created all kinds of problems in this
caucus balls five years in power have
been marked by trouble with scandals of
our patronage appointments and by
finances there were fears power rates
would more than double to repay a
massive cost overrun on the Muskrat
Falls hydro project he was even forced
to explain his part in paying his
daughter's bills after she became
embroiled with a drug addict who was
convicted of murder
but Baal insists he's not being pushed
out by his own party and he takes no
blame for anything it's billions of
dollars in profit in problems that we
inherited when you look at a project
like muskrat files it was billions of
dollars that we inherited as well on the
streets of st. John's Paul's departure
took some people by surprise oh I don't
know what to think of it I guess he's
got family commitments that are more
important than the and running the
province so his own choice I got a
respected ball says the next liberal
leader will be chosen before the
government tables its spring budget
which makes for a short leadership
campaign and he came to power Paul
became one of seven liberal premiers in
Canada currently his province in Nova
Scotia are the only two controlled by
Liberals Ross lore Global News Halifax
a former Canadian Forces reservist and
accused neo-nazi has pleaded not guilty
to weapons charges in the US Patrick
Mathews was arrested by the FBI a month
ago the 27 year old is facing charges
linked to his role in an alleged plot to
spark a race war in the US prosecutors
allege Matthews videotaped himself
advocating for killing people
poisoning water supplies and D railing
trains to incite a civil war Matthew's
attorney says he intends to argue that
his First Amendment rights to free
speech were violated more passengers on
that cruise ship in Japan are testing
positive for kovin 19 health officials
report 88 new cases today including at
least one Canadian a plane is on its way
to bring home Canadians who so far
haven't been infected they've been under
quarantine on the diamond princess for
nearly two weeks as Mike Armstrong
explains it was supposed to contain the
spread but may have done the opposite
the diamond princess is being called a
floating prison by passengers it's being
called something else by scientists not
a quarantine facility but an incubator
about 10% of the ship is now contracted
kovat 19 something went wrong this is a
highly transmissible virus and that's
one of the things that's of concern you
amplify that when you put it in a closed
space of the 3,700 people on the ship
when the quarantine started 542 have now
tested positive among the latest
Montrealer Judyann barrel home he's on
the ship with his wife men old Cadell
hasn't tested positive they're going to
be split up soon Belgian law was
supposed to be moved to a hospital from
the moment he leaves the room today's
says she has to restart 14 days of
quarantine things are going from bad to
worse healthy Canadians will be leaving
the ship the federal government says a
repatriation flight it's expected to
leave Tokyo Thursday preparations are
underway at the NAV CANADA center in
Cornwall Ontario where they'll be facing
another 14 day quarantine fences are
going up so they can get fresh air but
there's no contact with the public we're
expecting about 250 people but the
number tends to fluctuate all the time
now as was the case when Canadians were
repatriated from China everyone will be
tested before they board the plane and
when they arrive in Canada
those first two flights were close to
400 people none of them has tested
positive despite that and repeated
assurances from health officials I'm
concerned I've have kids area there is
some nervousness in Cornwall terrified I
am talking to people the town's mayor
says she spent three intense days
telling the public there's no danger but
part of the apprehension she says may be
because the whole thing was sprung on
her community with a warning
now one thing the US did that Canada
isn't is bring back diamond princess
passengers who tested positive they
brought back more than a dozen this as
the government should be bringing people
like her husband home they're desperate
she says the quarantine on the ship has
been a failed improvisation and she and
her husband are starting to question
whether they're going to get through
this ordeal alive Mike Armstrong Global
News Montreal China is deploying a new
strategy to stop the spread of covin 19
and it involves dirty money global
national is back in two minutes
in China one of the doctors on the front
line of the fight against Kovan 19 has
died
Leo xiaoming led the hospital at the
epicenter of the outbreak in Wuhan he
mobilized resources as thousands of
patients arrived each day is the seventh
health worker to die of the disease over
1,700 medical personnel in China have
been infected the viral outbreak has now
spread to more than 75,000 people
globally the death toll has hit a grim
new milestone rising to more than 2,000
the vast majority of these cases remain
in China and that's where new measures
are being introduced to further restrict
the movement of tens of millions of
people as crystal commencing reports the
World Health Organization is endorsing
China strategy trapped at home will Han
is a city of more than 11 million people
but all of those individuals have
nowhere to go
nothing to do and it's about to get
worse
a 76 year old says as the virus
continues to spread control measures are
becoming more stringent people cannot
easily get in or out of the
neighborhoods the streets of Shanghai
are also bare despite being home to more
than 24 million people students here
have been instructed to work online
never before has a government imposed so
many restrictions on the movement of
people but China is one of the world's
most populous countries gripped by a
virus no one had heard of until recently
you can argue whether those measures are
excessive there's an awful lot at stake
here in terms of public health and in
terms of not only the public health of
China but of all people in the world
while it appears the virus is most
serious in individuals over 40 and those
with pre-existing health conditions
little is known about it at the moment
we don't have enough data on cases
outside China to make a meaningful
comparison on the severity of disease or
the case fatality rate we're following
up with countries to get more
information about what happens about
each case and
the outcome until there is hard data
different strategies are being tested
the right moves will only be determined
after the outbreak is over crystal game
Anson Global News London and China is
taking more drastic steps to contain
kovat 19 even if it means cleaning up
its money the country's central bank is
destroying banknotes collected from
markets hospitals and buses in regions
most affected by the outbreak new cash
has been injected to make up for the
supply since January with four billion
un worth of fresh notes already
allocated to the city of Wuhan cover 19
is one of the reasons Air Canada is
predicting a bleak first quarter the
company is warning earnings will be
about two hundred million dollars lower
than a year ago executives point to the
suspension of flights to mainland China
and the grounding of the 737 max
aircraft their Canada has been back
filling the max Jets with leased planes
that have lower fuel economy and carry
lighter loads still ahead the aftermath
of a terrifying crash at the Daytona 500
you are watching global national here
comes handling up the outside crash into
the wall into the air an update tonight
on the condition of the driver in this
high-speed and fiery crash during the
last lap of Sunday's Daytona 500
Ryan Newman was leading when his race
car slammed into the wall launched into
the air and flipped several times he's
in serious condition in hospital doctors
say his injuries are not
life-threatening Boy Scouts of America
filed for bankruptcy today as it deals
with numerous sex abuse lawsuits tens of
thousands of men claim they were
molested by Scout masters or other
leaders decades ago they only recently
came forward because of changes to
statute of limitations laws in a number
of states the bankruptcy puts those
lawsuits on hold and gives the
organization time to work on a
compensation plan to settle those cases
in a statement Boy Scouts of America
says quote at no time has the Boy Scouts
knowingly allowed a perpetrator to work
with youth and we mandate that all
leaders volunteers and staff members
nationwide immediately report any abuse
allegation to law enforcement Donald
Trump used his presidential power to
grant pardons today he pardoned Eddie
DeBartolo the former owner of the San
Francisco 49ers who was convicted in a
gambling fraud case in Louisiana
twenty-two years ago he didn't serve
time but was fined a million dollars
Trump also commuted the 14-year sentence
of former Illinois governor Rod
Blagojevich convicted of corruption in
2011 charges that included trying to
sell then President Barack Obama's
vacated Senate seat today Trump called
the sentence ridiculous up next olve
apostle of our solar system's past
[Music]
scientists are getting a better
understanding of the building blocks of
our solar system tonight after studying
the most distant object nASA has ever
visited Eric Roth is located in the
Kuiper belt and as Eric Sorenson
explains it's helping find proof about
how planets just like Earth were formed
and liftoff at the New Horizons
spacecraft left earth 14 years ago
it's the then beyond part that was
almost an afterthought the primary
mission was to explore the dwarf planet
Pluto which happened with remarkable
detail five years ago suppose that there
were ice mountains but then New Horizons
flew off deeper into space to explore
the formation of planets and lo and
behold found Eric óthe just 35
kilometers long with stunning evidence
of how planets are formed it's just one
small lumpy object out at the far far
reaches of our solar system out in the
Kuiper belt but it's made a really
really big impact
all across planetary science and
astronomy we've long known about the
major planets circling the Sun in terms
of distance tiny Erica is way out in the
Kuiper belt a vast region of orbiting
asteroids comets and icy objects Erica
is six billion kilometres from Earth 44
times further from the Sun than we are
the remarkable findings from New
Horizons was that Eric Hoth was once two
objects and instead of a violent
collision they once orbited each other
and came together at about this speed
one to three meters per second they
almost docked in space Erik Haas shows
no fractures and craters that would have
meant a forceful collision instead it
suggests planets may have begun from
dust and small objects collapsing
together gently not violently planets
have been shaped by violent collisions
but how planets got started was always a
mystery if it is a very violent
collision how does how do things survive
Alena Hyde says rusty colored Erica's
gentle formation may solve the puzzle
this actually matches
is the the simulation predictions for a
more gentle collision so this really
changes how we understand planet
formation Erica a small object that
represents a giant leap in our
understanding of planets everywhere
meantime New Horizons has 10 to 20 years
of power left and is now on its way
deeper into the Kuiper belt to learn
more about the beginnings of our solar
system
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Robin Gill tonight your candidate is
white court Alberta we would love to see
you're part of this country so email
your pictures to viewers at global
national comm thank you for watching
Donna fries and we'll be back here
tomorrow have a good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]